everybody
for every person found alive more than a
hundred hours after the earthquakes
there are thousands now desperate to
stay alive individuals without families
families with little food and no shelter
in the cold weather in one town after
another
what will happen to these people he says
will the government look after us or not
we're all staying Outdoors now how will
this end so many buildings have utterly
collapsed and there aren't enough
machines to move all the rubble this man
points to the structural damage
buildings like his made of concrete too
brittle against the violent movements of
an earthquake
this house is uninhabitable says it's
fractured there's no hope that kind of
Devastation spans hundreds of kilometers
along the east Anatolian fault line the
first earthquake was the strongest in
Turkey in more than 80 years the second
major Quake a short time later followed
by dozens of aftershocks where the
tectonic plates push along the fault
line pressure builds until what's called
a strike slip a sudden horizontal
release on the surface buildings can
pancake that aren't properly reinforced
oh
Structural Engineers say steel
reinforcement can deform to keep
buildings from instantaneous collapse
but many of turkey's structures appear
to have been largely concrete although
turkey has building codes very much in
line with North American Standards if
they are designing to the code minimum
then they are designed to be heavily
damaged and the building are not
supposed to collapse so much the goal
for the building code is providing the
minimum safety so people can get out in
Carmen Mara scores of buildings were
reduced to Rubble next to buildings that
withstood the Quake critics say too many
buildings were not made safe or built
properly
the country was unprepared for this says
this opposition leader despite the
government of President erdogan
collecting billions in earthquake taxes
he says
lucky are the ones receiving food and
accommodation intent for the moment the
urgency remains finding those who've
survived but the crisis that will
persist is shelter because so many
structures have collapsed and so many
more are still standing cannot be
trusted Eric Sorensen Global News
foreign